foreign
Rising Sun man what a cool name for
pretty rock and roll what's up Carrie
Hi how are you guys outstanding what's
up
cool this is so exciting okay I promise
it's more exciting for us I promise
um so a colleague that I work with a
nurse her name's Erica she recommended
that I read The Total Money Makeover and
since I read it I've been kind of hooked
and
um just propelling forward to our future
of being debt free and I've been sharing
with my husband what I've been reading
and we've been applying it so in the
last six weeks we've paid off roughly 13
Grand in credit card debts
um I have another six grand and three
weeks we plan to pay off leaving me with
originally I thought it was two lines
but we actually have three loans so
after we pay off this last credit card
I'll have a horse trailer loan a Jeep
loan and then just paying off our roof
loan
um George has several uh for our roof to
Elite George has several horse trailer
loans so yes if I had a nickel yeah yeah
um so we have a 12 month plan worst case
narrow 18-month plan to be debt free
um and then into 18 to two years we plan
on moving south and you know taking our
horses and opening up a little a small
horse ranch
my question is every time I
pay off my credit card I call the
company and I have them close the
account I cancel it and then I shred it
but each time I just feel a little pit
of nausea and I wonder am I really doing
the smarter thing because I was always
raised and unfortunately I have raised
my daughters as well to think that you
need a good credit score to be able to
buy a house to be able to rent and to
buy a car and so I am kind of back
peddling with my daughters and I'm
trying to say hey I screwed up here but
let's look at this hold on hold on hey
I'm gonna let George solve the the your
mom of the Year already the process let
me tell you this
uh and this is a common misconception
this is literally
destroying the country
okay
yes this idea that once I say something
even if I'm passionate about it I
Proclaim I'm gonna do this when I get to
office I'm doing this and this and this
and then I get there
and I get behind the curtain and I
realize what I said I was about to do is
going to make everything worse or I tell
my son you want to be a man it looks
like this and this and this and then I
go to counseling for the first time and
I realize oh I'm the problem and then I
sit down let me I'm telling you I'll
tell you this the greatest gift you can
give your daughters
is the gift of saying hey I really
believed in this this is how I was
taught and then I learned something new
and here's the magic phrase I was wrong
period all wisdom all wisdom starts with
the words I was wrong and I learned
something new I I on my show the other
day I was telling somebody
um I give a nutrition advice which I
shouldn't have been doing and one of the
smartest men on the planet Dr Lane
Norton called me on my phone he goes hey
man you were wrong you give wrong and
you know what I was really grateful
because then I could go make it right
does that make sense so the greatest
gift you give you're not selling your
kids out or kind of jerking around no
you are teaching them what wisdom looks
like which is to learn something new
practice it believe it strongly Go full
force and then when you learn something
new do something different good for you
your mom of the year as George said good
for you okay
thanks okay so Carrie I felt the same
way when I was getting out of debt
because I was I thought the same I was
like well I gotta rent cars I gotta I
rent apartments how am I going to live
my life and then I realized the whole
thing is a scam because I went to my
apartment with no credit score and they
were like oh yeah that's no big deal you
seem to pay the first month's deposit
I'm like oh okay cool and then I went to
rent a car and they were like yeah cool
we'll just put a 300 hold on the debit
card and I was like oh okay cool and
then I went to get a mortgage and
there's a thing called manual
underwriting with a no score loan they
went hey do you have a 12 month rental
history and proof that you've paid other
bills on time and they were like okay
cool here's a mortgage and so it just
made me go oh my gosh we've been scammed
all along you don't need a credit score
to live your life
and I've got I George I don't know about
you carrying about you when I had credit
cards and I would cancel them
I would feel like I was
um cutting off one of my exit strategies
like I had 50 different exit strategies
in case it all went down and every time
I got rid of a credit card I felt like I
was shutting one big door and like my
body felt a little bit like okay now we
only have 49 Avenues to us if it all
goes down in the 47 and then 42 and then
right and I think it's it's completely
reframing debt is the is debt is the
prison you're locked in it's not the
solution to get out
so Carrie I'm going to give you and your
daughter some homework this is a fun uh
thing you guys can do together go listen
to episode 7 of the fine print I did a
whole episode called the dirty truth
behind your credit score I literally
call random apartments and homes across
the country and I ask them can I rent
without a credit score and I talked to
the mortgage lenders and I say hey what
does it look like for me to go through
this process of manual underwriting and
they explain it in full and so I think
it will give you a lot of peace and
confidence for this plan going forward
and let me tell you what's going to
happen you're going to pay off that debt
in 18 months and once you close all
accounts six to 12 months later after
that you're going to have an
indeterminal indeterminable credit score
but in that six to 12 months guess what
you're doing saving up a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses saving up the down payment on
the house and so you got plenty of
things to do until that credit score
Falls away and then you're gonna move
into that next phase of your life with
such peace and confidence because you're
not going to be drowning in payments
anymore you're going to have money in
the bank to cover emergencies so know
that you're doing the right things
okay yeah I appreciate that because I'm
I'm always sharing what I'm reading with
my husband my husband always looks at me
with such faith and trust and he's just
like are we doing the right thing and I
said according to Mr Ramsey uh
um well it's according to it's according
to Dave but it's also according to
millions and millions and millions of
people yeah the proof isn't anybody
anything yeah they owe nobody anything
so you are on the right path
um George I think it's important to add
one thing
um and that lead us into this article we
got here man
they might have to say no to some things
as they would start their business they
want it to look like this and have all
this cool like handy like awesome
artwork done in the wood and all this
they may have to phase that in over time
because they're going to pay at the
speed of cash right and so there is
going to be some oh she could look like
this right now but it's gonna look like
that in two years that's gonna be part
of it right because we're going slow and
we're doing it right that's always worth
it in the end yeah I mean swimming
Upstream there's there's downsides it's
harder to swim upstream it's a slightly
harder to live in a world where credit
is put on this pedestal but what you
also find is that you have less anxiety
and you're worried less about that next
paycheck and that counts for a whole lot
more than me playing this game so I can
have a quote-unquote easy convenient
life